imaginez deux personnes et s'est
confortablement à l'intérieur d'un
véhicule en mouvement
jusque là rien de surprenant mais en
fait nous avons 2025
ces deux personnes tandis que
tranquillement à l'arrière du véhicule
tandis que c'est une intelligence
artificielle qui conduit soudain un
piéton à paris sur la trajectoire du
véhicule
impossible de calculer en une fraction
de seconde cet ensemble de capteurs sans
forcer devant un choix éthique choisir
entre la vie de ses passagers
les a piqués dont comment cette peinture
est censé prendre cette décision de
manière mesurable reproductive alors
pour prendre une des conditions cela par
exemple de considérer la probabilité de
sauver les deux à la fois ou alors la
certitude de danse au rythme et passe à
ça quel sera le responsable de cette
décision
le propriétaire du véhicule le
constructeur du véhicule
le développeur de noter jean st ficelles
voir le chercheur ou la chercheuse à
l'origine de cette innovation
alors nous avons tous entendu parler
d'intelligence artificielle en main un
autre donc souvent ces internes flou qui
nous dépasse et qui sont m
peut-être fait pour nous embrouiller
bref on se voit faire ce soir c'est
qu'on va prendre une petite hypothèse et
qu'on va dire l'intelligence
artificielle pour nous ce sera sur pas
d'intelligence dans nos algorithmes
c'est à dire le fait de d'avoir pour
objectif de faire qu'un algorithme
réfléchissent quant à notre langue et
donc on va voir parution comment est ce
qu'on pourra même vous avez pu vous avez
pu entendre parler de manière
professionnelle
alors comment ça peut être un pointu pas
la remise pour dire ça va nous remplacer
notre métier va disparaître mais ça peut
être également lors d'une présentation
commerciale afin de vous présenter un
produit innovant qui interroge
d'intelligence artificielle grâce à des
termes sophistiqués mais elles laissent
également des images dans la culture
populaire
alors c'est à travers les films matrix
irobot terminator est ce qu'on peut
trouver intéressant danse et gym là
c'est le fait que le volet éthique de
l'intelligence artificielle est traitée
et c'est vraiment sous cet angle là que
j'aimerais vous parler d'intelligence
artificielle de sang alors pour
reprendre l'exemple de la voiture on
peut donc admettre que des situations de
conduite il pourra s est complexe pour
ans à roubaix
alors imaginez pour une voiture un
ordinateur qui ne pourra donc que faire
de froid calcul de probabilités on peut
retrouver deux exemples les vies
humaines peuvent entrer en jeu face à
des machines autonomes peuple en raison
des drones fed en autonome en effet les
forces militaires ont depuis l'origine
l'incidence ficelles décider décider et
compris l'intérêt à pousser la recherche
à tripoli depuis l'origine est encore
les développements de genre alors quand
je vous parle de drone je parle sud est
simple robot qui permettent
je parle bien de crimes de guerre qui
s'en étaient dame pour aller travailler
à lâcher des charges explosives sur des
zones de combat alors me direz on a déjà
vu l'évolution de d
de combat grâce à l'arrivée des drones
mais encore une fois ce moment là les
militaires étaient derrière et donc on
est heureusement un humain qui était le
dernier maillon de la chaîne dans les
piscines tandis que maintenant en toute
autonomie les les bons pourront être
relâchés je le pense qu'il est
primordial de légiférer autour de ces
aspects là de manière internationale en
fonction du contexte et de manière
nationale
évidemment cela nous permettra d'éviter
certaines dérives que nous promettent
des acteurs donnez vous imaginez quand
même pas imaginer que votre ordinateur
personnel est capable de reconnaître les
visages de vos proches de votre conjoint
de vos enfants également des objets qui
vous entoure et voir la bouille de votre
jardin
figurez vous figurez vous que ça vous
semble
à demain pour le moment il imagine ont à
nouveau on ouvre la réflexion en nous
disant que cet algorithme sera aussi
capable de prendre des photos à tout
instant de notre vie d'environ
inventivité pour ensuite vous laisse
suggérer qu'en étant des instants
marquants de votre vie
une avant semble heureusement est-ce que
ça commence à vous semblez un petit peu
intrusif elles sont commence à voir le
dépassement de l'assistance
personnalisée est réellement un au
respect de la vie privée on peut donc
voir l'intelligence artificielle comme
comme un art d'une problématique éthique
dans un trou au milieu pour identifier
avec les exemples que j'ai donné le fait
pour la considère comme une entité en
elle-même qu'à parle capable de prendre
des décisions et à qui on peut se
référer pour prendre des décisions
en effet la génération précédente
d'intelligence artificielle était
principalement autour du fait de
proposer des idées de proposer des
décisions est le dernier maillon était
du nord tandis que maintenant on arrive
à une totale autonomie
mais en plus de ces éléments de cette
intelligence un succès on peut exacte
dont elle exactement faire viendra
franchement avec la conception de ces
intelligences
en effet le lien entre les données et
les traitements des données qui
permettent de créer intelligence et
rennes - un enjeu éthique très important
en effet l'algorithme à lise et sam ont
besoin de données pour mettre en place
un apprentissage dans ces internats
informatique donc je vais super bowl du
terrain pour mettre en place un
apprentissage
c'est à dire à partir d'un ensemble de
données qu'on pourra lui fournir langue
hurri feu réussir à se créer une
expérience de cette deuxième expérience
à l'as à distance il pourra faire
référence pour ensuite prendre de
nouvelles décisions et c'est là dessus
que les bases et d'intelligence artifice
c'est donc ces enjeux éthiques autant de
la donner je retrouve et qui sont
exactement les mêmes que ceux du big
bazar auparavant puisque ces traitements
ne sont en fait que du big data adapter
les enjeux ne seront donc ce que dans un
premier temps la captation de données et
donc sa récupération qui pourrait être
plus ou moins respectueuses de la
libérer enfin on a encore en tête les
conditions d'utilisation assez flou de
la plupart de nos oiseaux
ça pourra être également autour du
traitement de ces données qui pourraient
amener à des discriminations et des
problèmes de
des points négatifs du prix en même
temps on peut trouver aussi ces
problématiques sur les traitements qui
seront faits et donné des données qui
ont été analysés par par cette
intelligence artificielle est également
qu'ils accèdent à ces données prenons un
dernier exemple les compagnies
d'assurance à la personne autres
professions de la statistique
ces compagnies utilisent intelligence
artificielle dans un rendu assez
particulier en effet elles chercheront à
obtenir avait profil des comportements
leurs utilisateurs afin de leurs clients
leurs clients afin de savoir lesquels
aussi ont des comportements à risque ou
non simplement grâce à votre race les
connecter tout en diffusant de données
qui sont dessus à votre assurance donc
elle ne doit s'est connecté c'est
principalement la fréquence cardiaque
le manque de pas par jour votre votre
révolution d'entre eux poids votre
assurance pour être amenée à connaître
une condition physique et à vouloir vous
classer dans les bons élèves ou les
mauvais élèves et vous proposer un bonus
en portant notre classement alors
évidemment ça vous semble être une bonne
chose tant que les tubes sont pas très
précis mais c'est jamais les moyennes
sont décidés à monter et que l'idée de
bonne santé et finalement se débloque
finalement pour que vous ne soyez plus
le temps vous retrouverez à être en
dehors des vendeurs du spectre dénoncé m
et vous parlez vous de bonus alors
perdre en bonus parce que c'est
nécessaire et quand tout le monde a le
bonus ont commencé
ça comme un ami
on n'est pas dans le big brother
panneaux solaires il est donc important
et nécessaire de mettre en place des
solutions pour ces enjeux éthiques
donc le premier neuf le premier c'est
problème reste le fait de considérer
l'intelligence artificielle comme une
entité à part entière qui seront
capables de prendre des décisions et
dans un deuxième temps comme la
considérer comme un gestionnaire de
données qui sera amené à faire des
traitements plus ou moins vertueux pour
ses solutions qui seront ils pourront
être proposées pour a d'abord commencé
par par une sensibilisation à
l'intelligence artificielle puis pour le
plus grand nombre afin que vous puissiez
comprendre tous les enjeux de cette
cette nouvelle technologie et vous soyez
peut-être même année à y participer
le deuxième élément pourrait être un
cadre légal à mettre en place au pouvoir
pour voir réellement encadrer ces enjeux
encadrer ces problématiques et pouvoir
éviter toutes les dérives qui auront
lieu par par les acteurs du domaine
l'intelligence artificielle c'est une
révolution technologique
alors comme un train à grande vitesse il
serait illusoire de vouloir l'arrêter
et c'est aussi des bonnes choses en
effet après tous ces exemples
c'est aussi les bonnes choses en effet
d'un point de vue médical
l'intelligence logicielle ça permet de
faire des diagnostics précoces qui
pourront sauver des milliers de vie à
travers le monde dans les prochaines
années grâce à la vision par ordinateur
et ça c'est souhaitable
donc on peut pas juste notre compte
ce que je vous propose du coup ce sera
de vous poser de vous poser les bonnes
questions à propos de l'intelligence
artificielle pas d'utiliser votre
intelligence naturelle et de et de
pouvoir réfléchir sur tous ces enjeux-là
est considéré que cette évolution
ce progrès technologique sera de pair
avec un progrès sur l'éthique et sur le
respect humain
[Applaudissements]